[Music]
this weekend a special edition of the
dish
Frances Bowman the world's most famous
proponent of open fire cooking open
fires of the oldest cooking method in
the world but Mullen has taken them to
new levels
he has been honing his primal technique
for two decades following an early start
in a far more refined setting classic
French kitchens on this week's edition
of the dish
Frances momen and fire the work began
just after 6:00 a.m.
Frances Mullin kept a close eye as two
of his chef's prep the day's feast there
are so many details it's such a fragile
thing to cook with fires people think
it's a beastly thing it's a manly thing
but it's not it's extremely fragile
first the hanging of the ribeye
slathered in chimichurri sauce each
suspended by wire measured and cut to
precision lengths to control for cooking
time and temperature a technique Mullen
created and is now mastered that was
followed by a dozen organic chickens
both are staples of Mullins custom domes
which are now a global phenomenon next
an array of vegetables and fruits
including pineapples and cabbage wood is
set around the perimeter of the dome and
then lit every day is different
depending on the wind and the heat of
the wood this morning you know it was a
sort of a blind date with this wood
which is great what the fourth the
fourth oh I didn't know what sort of
heat we would get from it but it worked
out well the fire has been such an
important thing for us not only for
cooking for shelter for warmth that
whoever sees a fire and sits by a fire
you just just drop it's primal
it's primal
a whole lamb was set on an Iron Cross
nearby then given time lamb is not
something you often see at North
American cookouts and certainly not made
this way okay and now I just flip it
five hours so far five hours so far and
then on this side too I'm going to add a
bit of this delicious moisture in ice on
it and that's a mixture of what butter
and herbs I get a sneak preview yeah
hold it from the very edge still warm I
always like to pull the first piece with
my hand is it nice it's a nice moment
also headed inside the fire with a whole
wild salmon yeah look at this beautiful
thing look at it and I'm gonna lean it
and make it sleep here because you want
the fish to be cooked but slightly tied
to the bone still you know so you have
to pull a bit we baste all the food
every hour and so even the pineapples we
put it in this syrup of pineapple every
hour so it's dripping it's wet Francis
Romans goal at this and every fire omit
needless ingredients which i think is
the most difficult thing in cooking you
know if you have a fish that it's just
cooked in the wood oven a and you just
put on it a little sea salt and olive
oil I mean it has to be perfect if you
hit those things it's the most delicious
things you will ever eat almonds
embracing of that bear style has been a
return to his roots in Patagonia I think
that childhood is where we always go
back sometimes you know I'm sitting in a
very difficult meeting and I'm anxious
and I go back to childhood I remember
the rain the snow the wind and I get
cured immediately you remember the fires
I remember the fires yes because we you
know we we lived with fires momen now
makes his fires for celebrity clients
around the world including David Beckham
and Guy Ritchie and Gwyneth Paltrow he's
been a legend in South America for half
his life but his 2009
seven fires put him on the map in the
United States I think that we achieved a
lot in the books but at the end you have
to start your fire stand in front of it
put your meat and understand what's
happening it's a craft cooking and you
have to do it there's no way out over
and over again over and over again
that's why you know sometimes my chefs a
chef I'm so bored of doing this steak
I've been doing it for two years I can't
stand it anymore and I say well you know
but what you're learning is not about
the state you're learning about how to
stand how to move and that's something
that you can't learn in a book and
that's the beauty of cooking you have to
do it from that bedded salmon to the
domed meat it's a crossed lamb every
part of the moment presentation is
dramatic
well I must say I'm very honored to be
here today
eventually eight hours after the fire
started dinner was served so we're gonna
serve first the chicken today string
hung chicken with cauliflower and a
criolla sauce salmon somebody else wants
some fish with cabbage and aioli lamb
with sweet potatoes butternut squash
onions and gremolata they give you one
of these guys ribeye with smashed
potatoes and a chimichurri sauce the fat
is very good for dessert burnt peaches
and plums with pineapple marscapone and
amaretto all along with plenty of wine
when people look at your cooking your
life everything what do you want people
to take from the Frances moment story
I think freedom I think there's a lot of
fear I think the worst enemies we have
our fear and routine because they both
freezes you know they when you're
fearful you're like that and when you're
in routine too you can get out of it and
I think that changes is the most
important thing in life to change the
process
that looked like quite an experience
delicious saying that did you I'm sure
invitation hmm nearby the dome is still
up so I can't promise you guys I can do
it like front maybe so can't promise
I'll do it like Francis it looked what
else yeah pretty amazing that fish
especially